so just really briefly my name is
Charlie Brinkerhoff I'm the head of
editorial at garden and yeah I'll be
helping to facilitate this amazing craft
LED Q&A today we're gonna be focusing
mainly on the sort of behind the scenes
elements of the show but before we kick
off I just really wanted to take this
opportunity to talk about the things I
loved about it - super briefly and I
think what I've loved about the episodes
I've watched so far is that for me it
really captures elements of my life as I
sort of like blackberry creative in
London and then beyond that on the more
serious side it doesn't simplify any of
the very complex conversations that we
need to be having around love and sex
and consent in 2020 it kind of I think
lets you sit with them and come to own
conclusions and I really really love
that and it also has I think my favorite
ever seen I've seen about period sex so
if you haven't yet you're both looking
to look for it see and of course the
cast the cast are brilliant amazing and
that very neatly leads us on to better
introductions I'm going to allow
everyone to introduce themselves just
really briefly in a couple of lines and
Michaela we'll start with you and then
routes you and then I feel like I'm
Charlotte already did such a brilliant
and lovely introduction for me so I'll
keep it short and Michaela Cole and I
created the show an act in it I could
give a show as well because I'm nothing
my name is Marie chase yeah I play Terry
in so I made this to you and it was
amazing
[Laughter]
sorry this meat in Armenian can you hear
me yes awesome my name is popper si do I
play qui me in the show and yeah I
similarly have an amazing time and I'm
really excited for people to see eggs
like Cheryl okay
so just before we get into the questions
I just wanted to let everyone who's
tuned in know there's closed captions at
the bottom if they're needed and please
throughout the course of the
conversation start contributing to the
Q&A section as well and we'll try and
answer as many questions of your as we
can at the end of the coudé so yeah
without further ado let's chat about
this amazing show um okay I wanted to
start with you and just to get a sense
of some of the real life experiences
that perhaps triggered the writing of
this show yeah
yes I guess um in 2016
I was very much like he are abetting
scene being able to see the first
episode I was doing an all-nighter and I
went out to meet a friend for a drink
for a break and my drink was spiked by a
stranger just like Arabella and this
really was the the roost of the entire
show
after that I then spoke to you different
people aspects um friends who had
experiences and trauma around consent
and used a lot of reality to inspire the
show which is additional amazing and I
was wondering in terms of arabela's kind
of impetus of what she sort of grappling
with also this kind of like and like me
didn't fade as well as her industry and
and really excitedly baa she's like
going on with foolish in her head is
trying to to deal with what it means to
be like a up-and-coming person within
the creative industries and I wondered
how much of that sort of print as well
um yeah yes I mean to be honest it
doesn't really
that part doesn't reflect me very much I
never had a second album blues or I'm
scared about the next thing I'm gonna
make you know and I guess with our
Abella another way that we differ in one
of the few ways we differ is there she
she never she has a lot of ease with the
people that know her work and come up to
her in those episodes that we see
whereas I think I definitely had a
period after chewing gum where I became
incredibly anxious all in my head but it
meant that my interactions with people I
didn't know who were very big supporters
of my work was sometimes access
experiences because of life just
changing and you know changing faster
than you you could have imagined so that
brought some anxiety a question to you
do you kind of feel you know in a URL
you will commune in the industry for a
while now do you feel so prepared for
the reaction the show might have and
that element of it because I think it's
going to be a massive hit personally so
I'm just interested in if you guys are
ready for people sort of like thoughts
and feelings being so projected and and
the conversations may be public it's
therapy
and definitely I I feel excited about
that because like that was one of the
reasons why I want it to be involved in
the project if on the script on paper
it's or it is it's asking a lot of
questions and it's provoking
conversation you know it's making me
think in ways I have thought about
things in in many times in ways that I
haven't and making me kind of like think
about a lot people's experiences for
different perspectives I think it's it's
crucial in terms of like its artistic
direction that in that sense and I think
it's it's vital that people do have
conversations off the back of it so but
I'm really excited I really don't know
what the response is gonna be like I
don't know what their reactions gonna be
already like people that I've spoken to
some people talk about how exciting it
is some people talk about how
controversial it is some people took
like there's lots of different responses
already you know so I think it's
interesting that this would be a big
spectrum of reactions but yeah I'm
definitely excited about Russia do you
have anything to add there taking all my
mouth again it's a conversation I think
you know conversation starts
conversations that have even started or
need to be started and will continue to
go on and a lot of people need to speak
and a lot of people need to be heard so
I guess were asked I'm as far as I can
be but I do expect it will provoke quite
a lot again like Popeye that's part of
the reason why honestly about this
project because it was conversations
that needed to be had you know to be
explored so I am excited but yeah we're
going to see how cool and then Mikaela I
know that this is from what I understand
one of your first experiences or it's
not your first experience of directing
is that correct yeah cool yes yeah what
was it like you know you've co-directed
a whole series at this point alongside
Sam Miller who I think what to Luther I
can imagine it was a really incredible
experience
yes and it was it it differed from
chewing
in some ways if it feels like I was
still being very creative in the
direction of chewing-gum but which I may
destroy you
co-directing and having the title of
co-director made me really appreciative
of for example the first ad who makes
the shooting schedule it just made me
think I guess I've written this thing
someone has to figure out how we're
going to shoot here how many hours we
have in a day to shoot what we have it
made me very aware of the time what was
also lovely was that um I am brilliant
co-director and I'm very early on we
were determined to become we would do
this with our hands one mind I learned I
learned to you to be patient and to
listen and to really pick your battles
you know that we've got this many hours
left to shoot the Sun down that the Sun
is going down what's what's at stake
what do we really want to think so I was
really taught that from him I had a
great team and I guess this time my my
vision felt like the first the beginning
of everything so every kind of way every
department took control and did their
talent ended made amazing sets and
makeup and costume the base point was
what did you have in your mind and how
do you see it and that was always asked
of me which it felt like I was given a
lot of trust and that that was great
I did it sort of you know push your own
creative boundaries as well in a way
like you know having to envisage things
over and over again like in such a
distinct way that makes me yeah yeah I
think so I think it also made me it gave
me confidence because I was being asked
what I thought and therefore I had to
share it and I think just sharing
gives them confidence and I was able to
articulate the things that I saw and
then I realized oh these things are good
they're they're worth shooting and that
was um that was nice it was nice to
realize that it was okay for my vision
to be trusted to kind of settle into
that they trust me and okay okay I can
imagine that's really tricky to get your
head round I certainly know for a lot of
creatives is something you know trusting
in yourself trusting in division is the
hardest thing a lot of the time and I
guess in terms of their character
development maybe that's something I can
put to you guys what attracted you to
your roles and and what do you think
that you brought to them each of you and
was that worth through each other so um
crazy enough I had always wondered about
how it would feel playing announcer
because I was like am i gonna play me so
we're gonna play an actor I'm gonna act
like I'm acting so that was a question I
had in my head but um there were some
dates where I thought you know there are
similar experiences so Terry is not me
there were elements that I could relate
to and yeah I just tried to make her I
mean when I prayed to Mikayla she said
to me that I mean we had a few
conversations where she said she
couldn't believe that I was Terry
because in her head it managed to
translate I found that that was really
touching because I was a beggar
semantical like I'd never obviously
known of the character Terry but being
called for her meant that there was
something in there and it was just quite
amazing yeah I think most yeah it was it
was an amazing experience
and the acting part was a bit of my
trouble but we got very cool I'm an
expert and like he definitely got
through it I'm not saying she's right to
UM see your words become human is a rush
of euphoria and that's what I felt when
I saw Terry's Marusia
and the thing with Popeyes is it's
beautiful feeling so thanks guys you
were made for the role it's both of you
it sounds like and just for those who
haven't watched the series that you both
play best friends of Arabella so of
Mikayla's character and the
relationships that you yeah you've
managed to create with both of them
throughout the series I think they're
really special and feel really really
true to life in terms of what it's like
to have best mates who really get you
but make mistakes and and also figuring
out how to talk to each other about the
most difficult things that going on in
your lives and yeah there's some really
beautiful scenes that you those who
haven't watched a series yet I've got to
look forward to we're just flying up on
the fact that you played a struggling
actor or I was so fascinated by that one
scene where you're trying to get cast
for a beauty advert and you're in this
position it's like just loaded as
microaggressions like I felt it under my
skin like and it was just like
everything about that scene just hit so
well and yeah I guess yeah so just again
a bit more context you asked about your
hair and there's like the weird comments
about like how many followers have you
got on Instagram or like whatever and
like undertones but like the diverse
nature of casting um I just wanted to
get your thoughts on that scene and you
know what what is that that is saying to
the industry at large it seems to have a
bit of a message um I mean the base of
the scene the way it was set up and
everything was very like a commercial
crafting I've been to a lot of them
so I remember stepping in the room and I
was like oh okay we're at the commercial
so that was that was interesting but the
little stuff like followers I heard
there some like that's what people do
now I have not experienced that myself
but I said that part what happened now I
know that they are quite specific what
they want in terms of a look so I know
that I tend to going to know
if I kind of have an idea what hair I
can go with so sometimes better a cup
like this or thing I might change the
hair up a little bit but these are
things that are like undertones that are
in these commercial classes the other
day you want to look like what they're
looking for so that is part of it but
it's also a bit worrying because as an
axe altering it's a commercial classroom
you still want to be known for your work
and not entirely your appearance but
because commercials are that quiet I
mean be a bit surface that quickly no
one minute to minute on the screen so I
guess they kind of get away with it but
um yeah it's crazy how things are
changing drastically sorry to said
myself or me that and then you've spoken
about one of the interesting things I
thought in terms of like the point
behind the scenes bit of filming this
show which was the fact that it's you
know it's it's 12 episodes you filmed
them sort of like intermittently from
what I understand so it wasn't like
lyric like a linear process and you sort
of commented on like some of the
difficulties and like getting yourself
in there like headspace to be like who
you are because the character
progression is so is so great throughout
the course of this series how did you
sort of how did you get yourself in the
mind frame to like be who your character
is in that moment at different stages of
filming yeah it's a it I think it takes
quite a focus on quite a lot of
concentration because and we didn't sue
in sequence you review very rarely do we
kind of I mean we kind of shot like the
first six episodes and then the second
six episodes arounds in like kind of
much did the first half and I saw that I
was like half which is helpful but um
yeah I think it requires quite a lot of
discipline and focus and actually
preparation I think I found on this to
be like really crucial to UM be able to
perform on a moment-by-moment basis it's
because they we're fortunate in the fact
number one we're fortunate in the fact
that like Michaela is always there so
you can always talk to
michaela about what she intended for a
moment or what she wants the characters
to be doing that at any given moment
which is the dream you know because
usually like it's just the actor and the
director and you're kind of trying to
approximate something that might relate
to the original story you know but like
to have the storyteller in the room with
you Ivor as she's directing or if even
if shouldn't the same scene as you is
was was really helpful so it kind of
like rooted you in the moment but what
you want to be able to do is perform
moment by moment and hope that they're
kind of like thread of moments comes to
amalgamates to make a kind of like
linear storyline but yeah I think for me
like I think having Makayla there was a
real lifesaver especially in those
moments where it required something that
was like quite extreme or demanding or
whatever you don't want to kind of like
just like go too far with it like it's
in an emotional scene where you could be
thinking about that for like two weeks
before I've got this emotional theme
that needs the shoot and then it gets
the way you like really go for it and it
kind of doesn't if incongruous with
what's happening in the rest of the
episode but suddenly is like quite
chilling than the huge letit of like
tears and whatever but McHale is like
McHale has always gotten story in her
head she always knows at what point and
at what point of like intensity or
whatever that way so like yeah I I think
that was really useful for for helping
projects that sounds really cool is that
are there any particular sort of scenes
who thinking of when you're thinking of
like that heightened emotion or where
you particularly like needed to lean on
her and get her feedback on things and
there's lots of things like I think like
the amazing thing about economy or and
really about all the characters is like
he's got a real spectrum of response to
the things that he goes through in the
episode without kind of like giving them
exploiters away like something big
happens to him in Episode four and for
the rest of this series it's kind of
like study and my various responses to
that and some of them are like quite
intense some of them are quite unhealthy
some of them are quite full of love and
joy and whatever like this so like kind
of everything was it
fused with something quite deliberate
and particular by doing the right thing
and why I guess it was my job to bring
that out on the performance and yeah I
mean that mousse does quite neatly onto
another question I had for you which is
about that scene that scene I think
you're referring to you at the end of
episode four sorry this is going to be a
spoiler for people who haven't yet
watched it um but it's it's quite a
graphic scene where your character is
sexually assaulted and raped by by man
on a date and I I know that you were so
supported through filming I think I'm
missing this this was for all of you
with an intimacy director and I just
wanted to talk to you a bit about that
process and how you know when you were
filming something that looks for the
audience to be so incredibly intense and
traumatizing you were sort of supported
through that because I imagine that that
must have been like a real sort of
concern for the people behind the scenes
yeah yeah I think I think um yeah you're
right it it's about the way the
performers are looked after in those
moments you know I think um there's the
the process was Clara and always had us
at the center of the thought you know so
we kind of met up we met her before we
even started filming to choreograph or
not choreograph but to talk about these
scenes and to kind of like talk about
about consent this is this is a show
about many different things but one of
the things that it kind of like
challenges our our questions about
consent so of course we need to be sure
about what we're what we're convinced in
furs were performing so we went with in
intimacy coordinator called ether
O'Brien who's fantastic
and she's worked on a huge she shows and
big shows but night sees see see the
real unique kind of like human being and
collaborator you know she really she
really focuses on you and what you
understand practicing and what you're
trying to bring out seeing and how
you're comfortable doing it and she will
overrule anyone should overrule a
director first ad
another actor in order to protect you
and there's something about that which
allows you as a performer to feel
relaxed and allows you to feel yeah that
you can focus on the job at hand and I
think like and I'm sure Michaela will
echo this like it applies to all
different types of scenes it applies to
about of course like really intrusive
and yeah violent I guess assault scene
like mine but it it also applies to like
the more lighthearted scenes which are
just about like I mean again I though
they're going for spoilers but you were
talking about a certain scene earlier on
like if that that needs to be
choreographed was the same amount of
dexterity I guess and delicacy so yeah
it was about allowing us to feel relaxed
and then we can really commit the size
of that moment because like with those
kind of beat to the story you can't
under play that you have to really go
for it you have to go there in order to
honor what the storyteller is trying to
communicate yeah I think the structure
was the structure helmed by an intimacy
coordinator was crucial to have what
happened yeah Michaela it would be great
to hear from you like you know how how
you how you did you were you involved in
finding the intimacy coordinator and
just what your experience was in like
making sure that you were bright with
sensitively around these issues of sex
and consent yes yeah i think someone
sent me an article with eat it was like
an interview in The Guardian I think and
I forwarded the email to Bill Clark my
courage that producer and I said we need
yes it was I mean not only is it
important because of the safety the
mental and physical well-being of the
cast it is also great because like Papa
said it enables us to go there safely so
you we can get what we need from the
scene with all the safety measures in
there
and what I like about ether is that she
is this kind of like energy that comes
into a sense and she is not beginning
from her head we're all quite heady
in sets you know were thinking about the
time the lines the best that ever that
I've got ether comes in and she's like
let's pretend to be bonobos and she
doesn't talk about that she just goes
into a bonobo sounds and begins
literally just goes on her knees this
rocks
everybody's patterns of being very heavy
and once you're like yeah no you do have
bodies let's just get into our bodies
and there's nothing wrong with this and
there's nothing weird and we shouldn't
feel like weird actors in the middle of
a set that has to do things this is what
we're here for and she definitely gives
that confidence in terms of writing this
kind of content which is its delicate
content it's very delicate content and I
think for me I always stayed with the
perspective of the experience of the
victim to survivor whatever you want to
call this person I never wrote outside
imagining them I got in and I became
them or like Arabella I already was her
and I tried to step into the shoes of
the character and see what I saw
so always beginning and ending with the
person experiencing rather than gazing
at them from outside I think helps helps
me to you to try and stay on a deadline
in terms of the content that's a really
really beautiful way of framing it I
think I actually just wrote that down
staying with the victim like sorry I was
thinking about that lines in terms of
just moving back to you working I one of
the things I also wanted to chat about
was your and Mikayla's relationship
within the series this is this is in
part because I obviously really enjoyed
the episode which is set in Italy and
you guys have
your wild night out and Michaela Wow
like you play someone who is on Molly
like you know to the end to work I
wanted to know how the pair of you
developed your friendship and that
chemistry with on and off screen because
I imagine you know it's the process of
it and I don't think you guys knew each
other like well prior to filming this we
didn't know each other well we had been
on top boy years years years years ago
and we'd only met briefly on sets and we
were in the same team but we went on
camera at the same time so we were all
in the waiting room with people I was
having like general conversation but and
I remember when I went into the room to
meet Michaela and the class American
hockey and Pamela I think that had
sealed issues before them we walked in
and it was just no chemistry immediately
and we sat there and we did the scene
I'm clean I just sat there looking at me
the whole time I was mad okay but it was
it was the most incredible energy I
remember walking after their feeling
what the hell was that but it was quite
almost tangible and I felt like I did
have a most amazing date of my lives it
was just like we clicked immediately and
it I was really excited about that and
then and I think we had our first
rehearsal where I then met Popeye
properly and the three of us were in the
room together and I was quite concerned
about it because I was like if we don't
all get on as off-screen I was gonna
work on screen but as soon as we all got
a living together it was just magical
and I think it really really translated
on on screen the Italy episode we
actually wouldn't play in the whole time
it felt like I was out on a night out
with a friend so we've actually yeah we
put quite a bond now we were fake
friends but now we're real right it
sounds like a flood
and it's because I've seen her tape so I
fallen in love with her already
like he her tape was so exciting but she
walked in and it's like I was so excited
by her and obviously he wasn't to know
how much I so it must have been weird
because I was just sort of like he's
like an exciting training yeah yes there
was a there was there was chemistry was
yes it's it works and it works off
screen as well with it was a nice very
good and I like you I mean like Mikaela
could tell the story of you if you
wanted to but it's actually a very
different type of story
yeah yeah yeah I've known Mikaela for a
long time we were at drama school so
we're in the same year at drama school
so we've been friends for a long time
and and like spoken regularly and
whatever and like I actually remember I
like and Mikayla's been writing the show
for a long time and like we've been
chatting about it like intermitted Lea
as she's been right in here and she was
talking about how it's going into
production and so and so and so forth
and like obviously I'm an actor here and
I'm just like good staying quiet you
know just like being supportive being
like and she's like yeah one day would
be good for there someone that'll be
good for there and they're like yeah who
knows right and then she fares right but
um the casting director amazing class to
direct the Juilliard pocket who I
actually have not sir and be grateful
for suggested me to her and Michaela was
like so anyway anyway I came in and did
the audition it was great it was
fantastic into me and Michaela and see
Michaela into me and Simon Simon and
everybody but like it's just for me it's
interesting because by our relationship
in space that calmer
outside of the idea of working together
in that way it's based like we've got a
friendship that comes outside of that
but as we perform together I think it
fit into that relationship the basis and
foundation of our friendship really kind
of where I think infused and the
relationship on-screen and they were
originally like as she said like the
first time we met we kind of like sat
outside in the park he enthusiasm to go
in and rehearse and it's just like it's
natural so they made it very very easy
to look like you like them and scream
that's wonderful yeah basic I just
didn't even it didn't occur to me that
it just never ever occurred minutes is
strange because you know poplar and I
are so close that at the time that I was
assaulted he is one of the people I
called in in those kind of hours where I
was like I think something's happened
and it's thought that and then I'm
talking to him about the show and I
think I don't know I sometimes wonder
what that was like any problem when you
came into the audition because it's kind
of trippy it's weighted because we're
making a show but er yeah I mean I don't
lie and I've spoken to you about it
before I definitely fact like that was I
found it really difficult to read the
first time I read it because obviously
it's fictional and it's not Michaela
story but like there are echoes and like
yeah reflections of reality in it so I
found it really difficult and I was and
I remember I rang Michaela and I was
like a shovel you sure you are you sure
you could do this like this would be
sounds hard and everything um and like
mckaela's like alien levels of amazing
so take something it would take someone
like that to be able to do it but like
yeah definitely when I first I first
we're there I was intimidated by his
closeness to reality I think that's a
good way of putting it did you find the
process so you'll probably be asked this
question quite a lot did you find the
process cathartic in a way especially
having such a long time to develop it
the writing deeply the writing you know
it was two years of writing this I never
did another job I wasn't acting in
something was also writing a show it was
the only thing that I did for two years
and you know traveling to places in the
middle of nowhere
where this is all I would do escaping my
habits to just think about this story
and it's his you know means I've had to
go to very dark places he you know I've
had some access I've had to go into the
trauma as if it is still happening as if
it just happened and then come out and
find the lightness in being able to know
that I am reflecting on something that
has past deeply cathartic and beautiful
that I feel so grateful to have had the
opportunity to do this and to spend so
much time of my life involving myself in
a fictional story that is a reflection
of the the real life that so many of us
are living if it's it's been the most
cathartic joy of my life
and acting was really more like as
cathartic as any other of playing any
other carrot I always find characters
very cathartic um but it also because
you're working with other other people
there's actors and it's um a variant if
there's like an intense play put we're
playing but it gets really dark and
really light and really dark but we're
playing I'm glee I'm pleased to hear
that it's been cathartic and it's also
amazing that you had that space to just
do it like yeah it's a rare and
beautiful thing how just we've got a
couple more questions for me and then
we'll move into the connect system yeah
how did this or descripton and the right
and change over the years that's one of
the final question to you Michaela oh I
mean yes in some ways massively in in a
few ways it didn't change at all there's
this so basically the way I begin I go
away I run away somewhere and I write
what I call vomit Ross so I did this for
chewing gum as well and I have found
he works for about created by various
artists limited and Phil was the head of
comedy at channel 4 when I did cheering
gum so I was always very determined that
if I am going to go anywhere I really
won't make sure I'm making a good
partnership I need to find film so I
tracked him down I found his office I
went to see him and he was game so I go
away it's the middle of nowhere and I
write the vomit sauce and then I deliver
them to Roberto who's also at valve and
Phil and Natasha the script editor and
what they do is they look at these sort
of 12 containers and form it and they
tried to figure out what's on earth I
might have been talking about so they
kind of go inside and they go tangerine
was that could you possibly what does
this mean
and then I they ask me all these
questions and I have to answer these
questions and as I answer the questions
I realize where I haven't been quite
clear in the vomit so then I go back and
I come back with draft one they ask me
more questions I come back with drum -
Josh 191 192 and then we have to choose
[Laughter]
alright so just one final question this
is for all of you and reach out I'll
direct it to you first and it sounds
like and obviously you can't say any
different because McHale is here with us
but it sounds like it was a really
positive process and like genuinely
positive process filming this being part
of the creative process and now you know
it's about to hit the screen does it
give you hope for how the industry can
progress you know the use of an intimacy
director a really close relationship
with the person who's directing and
writing it like does it make you hopeful
a hundred percent I have to say that
this whole the whole shooting process if
we did about six months and it was a
very respectful and safe set a whole way
through um I actually didn't do my
Sexy's myself I had a body double
because I wasn't comfortable to do that
and they were quite amazing to say it's
also a body double because it was only
necessary for the story and
was done in a respectful safe manner I
think there were many things put in
place because the sensitive there's a
real sensitive topics in it but they
made sure that everything they had a
therapist who was available to everyone
cost and crew and I think they did an
amazing job because I never had nobody
I don't I personally felt safe I'm
respected at all times for the how-to
issue as a grade there and it was
addressed in a respectful manner where
we came to a conclusion but it was
definitely definitely a really good
experience for me diversity as well
there were a lot of people who were from
different groups of life different races
and it was it was great because I never
ever felt uncomfortable at any point in
time and I think it was a complete vibe
I don't know if anyone else I'm sure
because every day was like I'm gonna see
my second family
I mean we're seeing each other every day
six months more less so it was a
wonderful wonderful experience and I'm
hoping that every other said I go on to
offer this in the law because I'm gonna
have issues with did you would you say
your experience was the same one set and
yeah I kind of think that you can't take
a step back once you start working in
this way expect I mean it's especially
with intimacy types traffic I like
working in this way you kind of think I
can't believe that it was ever not like
this like how like and it makes you I
think think think and feel for
performers that I've had to work in less
amenable situations in the past you know
it has to be like this at minimum grand
for words but you know generally I think
if you're gonna make a show that's kind
of like from Roasters and direct and
like confrontational and full of life
and rich as this you have to infuse all
levels of production with them with the
same kind of spirit and that's um I
guess that kind of comes from whoever
whoever happens to be helming the
project you know right yeah I think we
take on leads from Michaela see she
assured in the way
she works and it kind of like melts down
into everybody else so yeah I'd really
like to say that that that file or other
future projects with Bieber independent
sorry all right Michaela did you have
any final words just romantic uh yeah I
mean just to say if every day of this
year although very challenging was
beautiful and actually you know probably
you say you take a leave from me there's
something magical about television when
it works how it happened to be the most
perfect set of heads of departments who
went and sourced the most perfect
teammates Sam my co-director was he's a
beautiful man
he's collaborative he's kind he's
patient
he doesn't have ego and he didn't mind
just stepping back and letting me run
wild a little bit and we worked well
together
and it just feels really precious and it
was very diverse and I you know people
would sometimes look around and go wow
it's cool that we're all here all of us
you know it feels good beautiful and it
does give me hope so you asked me if it
gave me hope it does give me hope
because I feel like this show disease is
yielded positivity and it gives me hope
that maybe more opportunities will come
for creatives like me to have a chance
to do something like this I really I
really hope so absolutely and you know I
think as I sort of mentioned at the
beginning as a black British creative it
feels really special in it and amongst
everything else that it tackles I think
that it does a great job in representing
parts of my life via which I had never
seen on screen before so thank you thank
all of you that's all the questions for
me I'm gonna move on to the Q&A now so
I'll read out the name if the person has
got their name on and then she got some
questions so so far we've got about
seven seven questions this one is for
Makayla right at the top so an anon anon
frenum and anonymous attendee is asking
how did you decide how many episodes
would be needed to tell the
story fully and why did you decide on
half-hour episodes rather than an hour
episodes I really don't know why the
number was 12 I went into the BBC and I
said it's going to be 12 episodes and
Peter said 12 and I said yes based on
nothing rational and then it just
happened to work out it just happened to
work out so I don't know what was the
other question
the she asks or he goes why half an hour
instead of an hour oh that's it that's
it well I kind of had I probably have
more experience in the half hour domain
from chewing gum and I like I like pace
so the half an hour just it just felt
more comfortable for me I feel more
achievable nice and then this is from
Sydney from Michaela again asking
whether or not it was hard to get
committed and whether that was any
Christmas it was it was a really easy
process and so I think this is quite
unusual I have to say I I was lucky
enough to be working on black earth
rising which enabled me to meet peers
and then I went in to meet peers and
Charlotte's and I spoke about the
projects for about an hour and then a
couple of days later I got an email from
peers saying that they would love to
Commission it straight to series I
didn't write a treatment or a pilot I
just described it and they were
incredibly supportive peers read my
drama drafts I think I was like Sandra
so like 2:00 in the morning and he read
with enthusiasm and nothing support I've
been very lucky well any picking up the
emails at 2 a.m.
these are ledge well I mean up we
probably put them up at like 7:00
you've kind of touched on this a little
bit but another question to Michaela
from the same person is whether or not
you had a cast in mind when writing the
show or if that came a bit later it came
later I didn't I didn't I just the one
thing I did know is that I wanted Healy
harking to cast it because I'd loves the
thesis should caster she's very good at
finding people that seem authentic as if
they're not acting we've just found
people who were already living the lives
of the characters that's I've written
she has a way of knowing where they are
so that's her magic this is from the
Frances and Dave said thank you so much
for sharing your experiences and they're
super excited to watch the full show and
they were hoping that you could share a
challenging experience that you had what
whilst filming how you felt and how you
overcame it and then Mikayla the same
question to you except the biggest
challenge well whilst writing the series
you both look you don't have an answer
yet I really go because you're smiling
now say thank you so much um challenging
experiences on set I guess like I mean
I've really spoke a lot about it before
but like and some of like some of the
sex scenes were kind of like I suppose
longer and more more intimate than
scenes that I've done before so like I
have to kind of think I'd like I'd to
get over like feet like seemingly minor
things like my body image stuff and like
the idea was like the idea of like doing
something like that in front of a crew
of people that I didn't really know and
and I think we were shooting it like
we're suing it in the winter as well so
it was just like physically cold as well
like it was challenging in many ways
I guess but um I think for me like it
was just like open communication helped
me to get a bat like being able to
communicate things that I was unsure
about or communicating that I was
fearful about I guess and with people
that were willing listeners um and yeah
getting getting clear communication from
the intimacy directors director Michaela
was seen part of that about what we were
actually trying to do you know like
having clarity about that is infinitely
useful because it means they don't feel
like you're flapping around in the void
of my approximation yeah and for you we
thought of challenging having Mikayla on
set was a great great great thing
because if there was any confusion about
what the character was feeling at the
time that was great because Mikayla was
there and Sam was there and it was you
know a wonderful collaboration little
doodle discuss it at the same time so I
would only say you know just parents of
stuff more than anything when I wasn't
sure where the currentl was or what they
were feeling having Mikayla there and
Sam to help us get through it was great
having the script I felt that the writer
on there is a little ease of missing a
rough amazing um okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna skip over that question for you
just because there's a few more that
have come through for you and so another
person has asked to Mikayla did you have
any difficulty staying true to the
representation of how you wrote the
characters when adapting it to the
screen and if there was any sort of
pushback from higher ups or or anything
like that and then also any advice on
how to handle push backs if I don't know
if this is something you have
experienced
interesting mm-hmm yeah sometimes you
know you have an idea of what a
character will be like and sometimes an
actor will come and show you but it
could be this and a lot of my push backs
were internal so I was kind of thinking
that but that's not what I imagined so
sometimes I had to really wash away the
the the idea for what was going on in
front of me and see how that actually
could be fantastic
I think popper was one of those access
to me sometimes I didn't imagine it like
that but then I get up but this is so
much more complex and it made me go oh
yeah that old version no no no no no no
was this so you know push backs I think
a lot of those times my my team were on
the same page as me and I would
sometimes go guys I know that we had
this idea but this is why I actually
this might work and they were very they
were very embracing of me I have to say
sometimes I would be expecting
resistance and then I'd have to realize
that there what there won't be
resistance that they trust me it's like
I arrived with them with with baggage
but if ever I thought something is going
wrong as I would make sure I can
articulate why and then go to the team
and occasionally it can't be worked out
because there are so it's a huge thing
it's a domino effect there are
consequences of pros and cons so sort of
just them listening and and choosing
when to push back and I guess the way I
am I you know I'm I don't know that they
will tell you I'm naturally persistence
persistence my my can I'm never afraid
about push back I never
I'm just you have to you have to know
what you what is the Nugget what is the
center of truth in your in your project
what is that thing and there's a thing
in the middle of what you create and you
understand it Annie
sometimes can't be expressed in words
and sometimes there can be push backs
and notes and advice and warnings and as
long as you keep the Nuggets through you
can really try to try and find a way to
to solve problems you know a lot of the
push backs are about anxieties and
confusions and as long as you hold on to
the the thing you know to be true at the
heart of the projects you can become
flexible and figure out a way to solve
problems whilst keeping your integrity
and your authenticity as a creator Thank
You Makayla just to make everyone aware
we're gonna do two final questions in
the Q&A and then we're gonna end because
yeah it's been a lovely a lovely
conversation but during the end of our
time so the two kind of questions and I
think this one was directed towards
Makayla but I'd be interested to hear
just very briefly from all of you on
this was it hard scale character after
sort of long and difficult days of
shooting and what you did for self care
to sort of like separate yourselves from
the character maybe we could start with
you and just just a few eyes on it and
we'll go around and then one question
and that's it yeah I I yeah I was fine
like the end of the day to be really
important part of the process you know
so like the end of the day you drive
back to the makeup trailer and getting
because they cannot believe they're home
and always like make a point of like
having a proper like separate
conversation with people like with the
make fires with drivers with the ADEs to
kind of like wash that kind of
experience off I think it is important
that they go on back got back home
basically
and I at the end of the day when I leave
the character I take my wig Oh would you
take your wig off
Terry how the head they're telling was
that was the first thing to do
I also think my family to remind me of
Who I am and they're always around me
all the way wherever and that's kind of
my kind of self-care reminding me was
about to everything out Terry Terry
thumbs of the day I know you guys had a
really good and then yeah so just
finally Makayla to be honest this shoot
was a bit of a marathon for me it was
come home amend scripts learn lines
sleep trying a seven hours plan the
scenes that we're gonna shoot the next
day it was all a bit much but when
things were quite difficult
I spoke to knew we had a therapist on
standby the whole time loop lats and in
terms of taking the character home with
me I mean this definitely I
I the residue remains in me from every
single character I play I saw I tried to
just take the good bits from the
characters because I'm always taking
something I haven't mastered the art of
them of finding separation between
myself and the characters yet in
anything I've done I mean maybe that's
okay yes I think so
I find the characters I look for what's
inspiring about them and I try to make
sure those are the best I take thank you
guys for sharing very useful for anyone
elses and a performer final question
business from Michaela
so the question is whether or not you
have any advice for young black British
directors that wants to get into film
and TV a broad question but if there's
like you know key piece of advice that
you wish you had known as
young black director what would it be to
really believe in your vision and to
understand that when you don't
compromise on that thing in the center
that's what makes your your idea or your
vision special and that is what we want
to see the uncompromised vision that you
have and to not be afraid and to maybe
believe that people are here to help
they're here to help we are alright
thank you so much guys you're all
incredible I hope everyone Tunes in to
watch the series saloon yeah it's it's
really good remarkable remarkable stuff
and thanks for being so such brilliant
interviews with me today as well I'm
sorry also alright it feels weird not
smells like give me a hug
but like this is it
[Music]
[Music]